tout le week end ils se sont relayés
pour préparer les sandwichs tenir la
buvette ou assurer la cnil 300 bénévoles
au total tous originaires de cette
région du centre bretagne aux confins
des monts d'arrée avec un seul but
assurer le succès de ce festival des
vieilles charrues qui est avant tout le
leur on doit quand même centre et des
noms comme une petite ville le sang
devant taille est à traduire et on va
montrer qu'on est capable de faire
quelque chose
j'espère qu'on va être conne et après ça
et d'année prochaine il y aura cent
mille personnes
en trois ans il en aura 150 et et leur
disons tournera 250 et 300 mille trois
cent mille peut-être pas tu n'es pas
loin de cent mille sans doute pour cette
septième édition des vieilles charrues
un festival à la programmation des plus
éclectiques puisque capable de réunir
sur une même affiche 2 touchant tant
indie pop et charles trenet
pas moi
ae
vidéo
elle
revoir paris il n'était pas question on
était trop bien à carré car la plupart
ont passé ces trois jours sur place dans
une sorte de woodstock champêtre où la
fête compte autant que les concerts un
succès qui doit beaucoup aussi un
argument de poids pour les spectateurs
souvent très jeunes
le prix de son mal pour 25 groupe c ça
fait même pas diva le
on voit on voyait pas pour mettre france
c'est cool quoi mais lorsque les choses
sérieuses reprennent il n'y a pas photo
c'est louise attaque qui fait un carton
fort de ses quatre cent mille albums
envolés en quelques mois violon
énergique et voir où le temps d'un
week-end les mélodies tantôt romantique
tantôt acide de la révélation française
de l'année ont déferlé en raz-de-marée
musicale sur la bretagne centrale